per questo a tuo agio di mio padre
quella sono io che partirà a quello ciao
ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di vita
buttata il tema della puntata di oggi è
tatuaggi orribili per un tema così
importante ho pensato di imitare
all'interno degli studios di casa mia
una persona che potesse in un certo
senso essere un esperto se non altro non
conosco personalmente dei tatuatori e
quindi ho pensato che fosse la persona
migliore
diciamo commentare ciò che vedremo deve
essere comunque un artista ora io la
fortuna di conoscere un disegnatore
marvel delle ultimi progetti ci sono
iron man guardiani della galassia e un
sacco di altre cose fichissime che
riesce a creare con le sue mani ecco
perché è con immenso onore e anche con
un pizzico di spocchia ed è un piacere
piacere a di avere ospite delle ospiti
anche un grande jazz ho detto tutto dove
ha detto lui ha detto tanto partiamo per
noi siamo dato a dire l'altro giorno ero
io abbiamo non serve essere uno stilista
per dire che se non più di me nemmeno e
serve essere uno che crede sapori per
dire la puglia allora io ti voglio
onesto sarò franco ha ospiti decisi di
tatuare viene scritta caos su invito
tutore ed io non amo molto le crete
studiati in risultato fu che descrisse
caos in greco comperò la alfa brera a
siamo stati costretti ad aggiungerci una
rondine 50 ex amici xi di farmi questo
benedetto tatuaggio sulle costole quindi
già immaginavo dolore così di farmi come
si vede le ombre come tutte le
professioni dei di peter pan e wendy
wood
si no ma diciamo che la classifica è
prima o poi andava bene cari che però
esatta riconoscibili almeno il
fratellino e in blu ray è perbene
pensieri felici di crisi wendy con
l'asma e poi c'è ogni cosa
lei continua la foto così sia l'anno
scorso ha deciso di sistemarlo però
lampo risalvato video live dettagli
l'orsetto l'ombrello quindi un po
comunque verrà quindi è sempre un po
sfortunata che ebbe il figlio ha
aggiunto dettagli
l'orsetto non l'ombrello era andato via
si è alimentato l'ombrello volevo
raccontarvi del mio il tipo di tatuaggio
ha fatto da un tatuatore che non hanno i
cozio però questo non è anche presso
alcuni negozi e poi adesso mantenga il
calcio per aprirli non una sua vita ma
non raccomandabile di farmi che si
tratta della mia e catto mafalda però
sembra tutto tra le fondatrici accetto
che mi scozzese in una caffettiera
sembra con i soldi supponibile avanti si
guarda ma lì non ammazzare se quest'anno
tatuaggio inferno in cui la mia vita era
le altre hanno mosso dire tanto
ed è tornato orario sembra una cacca
ecco cosa wow
ciao ospite ti racconto di uno dei tanti
tatuaggi
ovviamente il peggiore quando andai a
bologna insieme una mia amica ci siamo
tatuate insieme sul fianco la faccia di
un porco ovviamente era un reddito o
coperto con un altro tatuaggio non fate
mai un porco devo dire una cosa
villa non me la sento più parlare del
motivo per cui si chiamano le porcone o
cioè nel senso credo che sia anche bello
lasciarlo un pochino così
l'emarginazione
ma anche perché siamo passati dalle
porcone ha comunque dei bei fiori pare
affatto basile si rispetta il primo è un
van gogh 6 megabit
in realtà no e poi se i denti da
luminosi che ti tipo come se questo must
e riconoscere tra i denti quando per
coprire quasi devi fare una cosa ancora
più grande se team ha scritto grande
finchè alla fine non copri tutto il tuo
corpo morto ed è così che proveniente
partito essere forcone con la sua mille
manco a me e federico ciao ciao ospita
rho mi sono fatta questo tatuaggio
perché etico su soprattutto le cose che
si incontrano in uno solo
assomiglia a un cane che si è imposto
quando a lungo il braccio e fa molto
ridere perché la gente ma chiederò un
penalty a samantha de ora
la gara sembra non far musica si
incontrano nella loro vita è un dire
niente coraggio
ok dove ce l'ha poi ai miei ho
intravisto eccoci qua
no abbiamo capito tutto ciao come ospite
riprende la cosa che ti prego fallo per
la mia salute mentale psicofisica allora
da come puoi vedere paio di casi non
hanno appassionato e poi appreso che
proveniamo tantissimo a farlo dovrebbe
essere una mamma ma sembra più un lama
di affatto frontani punti devo dirlo ma
non sapevo che cosa ha fornito dal
padrone una parte del corpo insomma sul
p romanzo inizia una mazza anni fa ha
compiuto 18 anni mi fece tatuare un
cavallo facilitazione da parecchi anni
ecco dunque cavallo fece vedere un amica
che mi disse
c'è chi 78 alla cina per essere anche un
tatuaggio
inutile dire che dopo fortissimo bianca
perché la criniera come la gamma e carlo
che cosa abbiamo visto cose che voi
umani cioè questo almeno si aspettava
questo è veramente dalle spire
presidente di più
66 meno chiamino canzone 5 5 però
recuperabile non c'è questo che ho dato
io ha detto madonna mia mesi per le è
proprio lei è proprio l'esclamazione che
ti milano vedendolo per questo dovette
al posto che stress health e stringhe o
meno ma problema oltre che essere il
ritmo tutte le persone che conosco
dicono che sembra scritto alice anche
galvagno per sé non è un paese anglofono
italia per cui zai madrina liberale che
così è partito ri ri dovremmo ciao ciao
ciao fratello dalla fantastica risalta
ti voglio raccontare di quando decisi di
tatuarmi museo stilizzato di un cavallo
dopo di che per fortuna un altro
tatuatore riuscito a sistemarlo mi ha
fatto sembrare un cavallo affetti
potremmo
la kia traver ma lui si chiama rota dei
cavalli salvo in qatar da disegnatore i
canali sono difficili si canta questa
muscolatura vista che devi conoscere
bacia una cosa complicatissima al canto
un po improvvisati una no perché viene
poi grandi maestri sono i disegnatori di
tex che fanno cavalli in continuazione
cioè si può claudio visto di lato al
cantante il copertinista di tex rock
però che paga la sfida cavalli a perché
io invece sono arrivato non si può
copiare dovrebbero sposare cavalli però
scuse non vale perché tutti i segni
operiamo
ma tu hai detto che ci stanno tutti
questi muscoli a vista sembra tende
[Risate]
parecchia obara che ha preparato è
affatto un drago c'è anche gli zoccoli
vai col mio che a un cavallo santi vari
così ho provato aveva riconosciuto che
la lotta la tatuatrice riguarda intenso
qui abbiamo una mi dà l'idea di un
dinosauro del mesozoico amy era un
mostruoso
siamo arrivati a fini di questo video
ringrazio ma lega per aver preso parte a
non darmi non ha più uno paesi
soprattutto tutte vicine rai mai più ma
manca ricordo ai tatuaggi
ricordo con un lato dalla gente fidata
la controlla degli stencil non andate
proprio voglio sapere se conoscete
qualcuno che è del tutto aggiornabili
siccome però le cancelli e qualora il
progetto dei cancelli only copra ma se
ne avete qualcuno in particolare
fatelo venere toccandomi su instagram
che lui taggate ciclista che l'abate
fateci di vedere come sempre l'invito a
iscrivervi a questo canale ad attivare
la campagna dell'ina delle notifiche per
non perdervi i prossimi deve usciranno
noi ci vediamo il prossimo giovedì
sempre 14 con un altro vita buttata ciao
ciao
questo è il deforme gladiatore e sembra
la montagna di fermato di una di una
fava è una certa luca conosce questa
paura ti sfugge